Oh,
have you ever wondered how ships,
which can waste such large amounts managed to stay a float on water while you
cannot walk on water?
Well,
the answer isn't too complicated in this water vessel technology has been around
for thousands of years.
We'll start with something called buoyancy burns.
He is,
he had barely for an Arabic to Florida,
top of body of water or another liquid or even air and object's ability to flow.
It depends on its density relative to the density of water,
not necessarily its size or total weight.
For example,
uh,
sheet of aluminum foil crumbled into a ball sinking a body of water if dense
enough or a fun role to be flat.
The same aluminum foil float.
This is because of something called Archimedes principle.
Archimedes of Syracuse was a Greek scientists to discover this and his bathtub.
According to legend,
it basically states at the buoyancy or floating force exerted on a body immersed
in fluid is equal to the weight of the fluid which the body displaces.
Therefore,
a thousand ton ship must be built wildly enough to displace it.
Thousand Times of water.
If it's not,
it will sink.
And if the ship or to carry too much cargo,
it would again,
sink.
Ships are hollow filled with there and bill to displace water.
You however,
cannot walk on water because you were at to dance while standing.
However,
float on your back and you will of course be able to from our video on physics,
science in general,
and much more.
I'd invite you to subscribe and check out my channel and also be sure to check
out Royal Navy ball on Facebook.
It's video was made possible through their support and if you're interested in
in shifts,
they post frequently about the Royal Navy of the United Kingdom,
one of the greatest navies to ever set sail.
Thank you for watching.
[inaudible].